right now my last thought
would be i've had a good life
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan what if
everything you've
ever been told by society is wrong
everything everything not morally wrong
but simply incorrect or misleading
would we all benefit from maybe doing
the opposite
that's what i want to talk about today
we got so much to talk about
let me start my little timer here
because i want to make sure we stay on
time who knows maybe our maximal episode
today will be extra extra long this week
over on patreon this thursday but uh
before we get into
thinking the opposite we're gonna be
talking about this book as well
it's paul arden's book called whatever
you think think the opposite i'll hold
it up if you're watching it
on youtube here so we're going to dive
into this i've got some places mark to
cover but before we get into that ryan
i want to talk about someone who was
sort of the portrait of
doing the opposite hmm and
i didn't expect i'd be this sort of
profoundly affected by this
but dmx died the week before recording
this so by the time this comes out it'll
be
about a week and a half ago and
i wasn't a big fan of his music yeah i
mean i
i knew his music everyone knew his music
yeah you know he was the first artist
ever who had five number one albums his
first five albums were number one
albums oh wow not the beatles not
uh michael jackson not james brown
not prince dmx earl simmons
wow and so and he had you know an
amazing career especially those
first four or five albums were often
considered classics by
you know a lot of critics and and so
his music didn't always necessarily
resonate with me you know we grew up in
the midwest and and
at that time you know we were teenagers
when or i guess late
teens at that point when 98 99 we were
getting ready to graduate high school
and so that is a formative time in
someone's life in fact if you look at
anyone who's in their 40s 50s
60s they tend to still often listen to
music they listen to
during high school years oh yeah i
totally
fall in line with that yeah yeah i mean
i still seek out new music but it seems
like
strange that the bar is almost the music
that you had
in your teens yeah and
for whatever reason his music didn't
necessarily speak he had some songs that
were
slipping was a song sort of about
struggling and dealing with struggles
and
he had other songs like that but he also
had like sort of a lot of party anthems
and you know i'm allergic to partying so
right it didn't resonate with me but i
didn't think i'd be so profoundly
effective in fact
i'd never met the guy didn't know him
the only other person who was famous who
died who's had
a effect on me when they died was david
foster wallace
but i was a huge david foster wallace
fan when he
passed and then when this happened i
started
sort of reflecting and questioning like
because i
i was like a mess for like a day i was
crying i couldn't figure out like
why is this so wow dms over dmx
yeah because i never thought about his
music never thought much about him as a
person
i knew knew of him but i was not
profoundly affected by his body of work
and then i realized like oh well
he was sort of this portrait of
authenticity
we're talking about today about about
thinking the opposite but he sort of
went against the grain
everything that we're told by society is
often an affectation
in fact i think if someone had performed
or
affected themselves like dmx and they
weren't dmx
imagine how corny that would have been
with the barking and the growling
it would have been a parody yeah yeah in
fact he was the only person
who i feel like could pull it off in a
way where it never felt
affected it never felt like a parody
yeah it felt
authentic yeah and there was a certain
sort of timeless cool to it as well
um i was talking to jess the the gala
manager our social media accounts this
week and we were
sort of laughing about how things that
are trendy and influence or trends and
stuff like if you
take someone who was really trendy like
back in 98 or 99
like even if you i saw a video of of dmx
with jay-z in 1998 or 97 or whatever
and dmx looks like dmx and jay-z
looked like he came out with a time
capsule of 1997.
it was a parody the oversized jersey
the giant do rags and and it fit for
that time but it wasn't
timeless and i have this picture here
jordan let's uh actually i can just hold
it up for
youtube if you want to look at it here's
a picture of dmx i think it's from 98.
and like you he's some pitbulls yeah you
could have taken this picture today
and there was a certain timelessness
about it i'd agree with that
and you would have said oh yeah like
someone did this picture today it
wouldn't be out of place but if you took
the average person from 97 and took a
picture of them just like if you took
the average person
in 2021 and you look at it 20 years
later it's going to be like oh my gosh
we dressed like that
right right like jay-z in the oversized
jersey right like
yeah not so timeless yeah and it's kind
of cool because you go back and see his
time capsule like what were we doing oh
we were trying to be trendy
but he was never trying to be trendy in
fact at the time when
he was making music even though it
wasn't music that deeply resonated with
me
i respected it because at the time it
was
p diddy and shiny suits and high
production
value and he came out with this video
his first video was get at me dog and it
was a song that was like
so grimy and raw and the video was
filmed at the tunnel which was like this
famous underground club and it was so
gritty and raw it was like you
recorded with a camcorder or something
yeah but there was this
authenticity there yeah so he died of a
drug overdose
and it's funny because every time i hear
like a celebrity dying over
like a drug overdose there's a piece of
me that gets it
it's like they top out at a certain
point
so dmx had five number one albums um his
sixth
album was a couple hundred copies shy of
being number one wow
yeah but you think about his party
anthems and stuff but it's like you get
wrapped up
in that constantly feeling good
and then it's you know now when he uh
you know fast forward to when he isn't
producing number one albums
like he's missing that hype of having
that number one album
well guess what makes you feel great
some really good drugs
that becomes the new number one album
yeah right exactly
so um it's funny because a piece of me
wants to be like why are we why are we
even talking about this guy
exactly out of a drug overdose right but
then the other piece of me is like
you know i've been there with with drugs
and alcohol and overdoses
and overdoses and it's very it's very
it's a very
simple easy solution it's
bad it's a bad solution to a really
difficult problem well this is what i
say the the the solutions are the
problem
this is like the extreme example of that
right where like it does
it is a solution sure but it creates
more problems and i think sometimes we
don't think about like we we see a
solution in our in our society and we
say well
do the thing that fixes the problem not
realizing that yes it does fix the
problem but it creates
much greater problems yeah in our life
totally he had this line in at the
beginning of slipping which was my
favorite song of his
he said to live is to suffer but to
survive is to find meaning
in the suffering amen that's like sounds
like buddha yeah
it really does it's you know sort of you
know i mean he was a very
religious man as well and the thing that
i
i see with dmx is that he was
suffering his entire life and he
suffered especially
when he became famous yeah and in fact
uh
you and i were talking before the
podcast he had this
he had a moment where he became world
a household name world famous and he was
praying and he said
god why did you give all this to me i
didn't ask
for all of this yeah because he knew
also like
oh i know what this is going to do to me
yeah
and and he he recognized that maybe he
didn't have
the tools or the strength or or whatever
to
deal with all of this yeah and so
i i i the reason i i felt so shooken up
is because i went
and i sort of fell down the rabbit hole
i was watching these old interviews of
him
and i could see the pain and the
suffering
and we identify with that and that's
really what stood out to me
it wasn't this great man with this great
career and the number ones yeah
so what what was what really resonated
was the struggle
the realness because we all struggle
yeah and what a great
i don't know great example of uh
having everything being rich and famous
but you still struggle yes there's still
a struggle
well someone asked him in an interview
now that you have all this fame and
money
what do you want and he said a smile a
day
and and to me in that moment it was
really sobering because even he
recognized and by the way you didn't see
him doing you know
wearing millions of dollars worth of
jewelry and driving around in
lamborghinis and stuff like that
i mean in fact he used money he was a
very
giving person as well in fact you saw
that he actually went broke in the early
audience because he was giving away all
this money to schools and his friends
and
and and you realize like oh what he was
trying to do was contribute beyond
himself he did that with his music
and then he said well i've got this gift
let me find ways to to give it even
while he was
struggling never pretended to be someone
that
he wasn't and that there was a certain
authenticity in that
and when i went back and watched his
interviews now sort of in retrospect
i saw how much pain he was in in a way
i heard joe budden say this this week
like don't feel sorry for him
because he doesn't feel sorry for
himself at this point because
he knew how much he was suffering and
wanted that
suffering to to end in fact we even
started
this episode instead of our normal
advertisements suck
there's that line if i drop dead right
now my last thought would be
i had a good life yeah now for him a
good life wasn't a perfect life and it
wasn't the ideal life
it was a lot of suffering a lot of
struggle it was finding meaning
in the suffering yeah last two and a
half years for me
have been extreme suffering i wake up
most days and just terrible crippling
pain i rarely talk about it on the
podcast
uh because i don't i don't have any
desire to
bother you all with it but that i think
that's really what
what broke me down this past weekend i
was going through these interviews i saw
the suffering in him and there was a
certain gratitude
not that i'm glad that he died but i'm
glad that he's not suffering
anymore yeah because there was man there
was
extreme suffering and he was
he had faith but he also had like all of
these flaws
and we didn't love him despite the flaws
i think
i think in a way we sort of loved him
because he was publicly flawed
there wasn't this veneer of dmx yeah
it was raw and gritty and honest
in a way maybe not even honest probably
not the right word it was the truth
even when he was lying you could see
when he was lying about his drug
problems and rehab and overdoses and
things like that
you can see the truth in in the
suffering
so before we move on to this book think
the opposite
i want to play this quick excerpt from
interview he did
this was a month before dmx died it's
this little butterfly story
let's have a listen actually you know
what before we get into this let me just
give you a
quick preface the the story he's about
to tell is when he's a little kid
and he's chasing a butterfly i saw a
butterfly
the size of my [ __ ] hand monarch
whatever beautiful
and i was like cheesy
and it went in the neighbor's yard that
had wildflowers he had a beautiful
garden
and like this big you know
you know not much of a yard that type of
[ __ ] and i
jumped over the fence and i must have
stomped on every flower trying to get
this butterfly
and i dove on it and caught it i [ __ ]
his flowers up
and i [ __ ] the butterfly up man
i put did not put in the jar i was happy
because i could i was able to say i
caught it but it died
i killed the most prettiest thing i'd
ever seen in my life because i wanted to
keep it for myself
that's what's not learning that's a
lesson man that's well
i killed or no i yeah i killed the most
beautiful thing i ever saw because i
wanted it for myself
yes what a minimalist
well i mean there's so much there's just
so much there's a lot of metaphors with
that sort like
we all we have talked on the podcast
before
about a butterfly butterfly is beautiful
to capture it
pin it down yes and you try to study it
it loses a lot of its beauty and it's
all
this is even more of a metaphor because
in order to capture that butterfly he
had to stomp on all these beautiful
flowers
right yeah there's there's something
really
really really enlightening there for
sure you know what he showed me
and i not recognizing until now at age
39 but
he showed me that it was okay for men
to cry and because like he was
a highly sensitive emotional person he
was a very
highly sensitive badass right that's the
thing like he would
no one messed with him ever right but
like he would also cry in the middle of
a prayer on a radio show
or he would you hug his son
after i mean he had 15 kids oh wow
um and so but he get reunited with his
oldest son
i think he's 28 and like they would hug
and and you'd see him just just melt
and there was no facade there and i
really think that's
what i appreciated about him flaws and
all
and i mean the flaws are too many to
name in a single podcast
but if he showed us anything he showed
us that like
that i mean life is ephemeral right
and and then it's never going to be
perfect we can't capture the beaut
the beauty it ruins the beauty and i
feel like he
he taught us so much there so rest in
peace dmx
let's move into thinking the opposite
yeah so this is a book that i read and
you can read it in a single setting it's
really short
yeah and when i say i'm the slowest
reader i mean
it's mostly pictures it's basically an
adult picture book
well adult that sounds like playboy or
something that's not what i meant
but i i marked a few things here let's
just go through these
because paul arden who was in uh
marketing
he i hear some profound wisdom in in
this book not all of which i agree with
but that's okay yeah the uh description
here on the inside cover this book
explains the benefits of making bad
decisions
by the way on patreon this thursday
we're going to do a whole episode about
the worst
advice we've ever been given and we had
a bunch of uh
listeners write in with their worst
advice ever and we're gonna
sort of dissect some of that it shows
how risk
is your security in life and why
unreason is better than
reason it's about having the confidence
to roll the dice
so let's talk about that here's my
favorite story from here it's on page
18.
hold this up for youtube there's a guy
well i won't even run it let me let me
read it first
this is called the right exposure there
is a story of a professor who was
bathing in the river
cheerwell in oxford at a place called
parson's pleasure in which he was
which was the custom to swim naked as
the professor got out of the pool
a punt of undergraduates glided by
whereupon he grabbed his
towel and wrapped it around his head
and you've got this picture it's a
drawing here of a
naked man who instead of covering
himself up quickly with the towel what
is he doing here
well he's thinking the opposite yeah
because it wasn't a problem that he was
naked
until he saw them not that they saw him
it's that he saw them was the real
problem because if he didn't know he was
being observed
it wouldn't have mattered anyway you
know do you know what i interpret
dude i totally interpreted this story
differently so for me he was thinking
the opposite in the sense of
uh because most people would cover
themselves yes to not be exposed
right but what i got out of this was his
thinking was that if they can identify
me they can't tell that it's me
okay that's that's one interpretation
i'm not saying it's a wrong
interpretation
interesting but you're saying that he
did it so he couldn't see them out of
sight out of mind
i'm saying the more the more sort of
profound metaphor here is that
if we don't care what other people think
then we can continue to be
as we are yeah naked to the world
so to speak interesting the very next
page is a little something called
trapped
it's not because you are making the
wrong decisions it's because you are
making the right ones
we try to make sensible decisions based
on the facts in front of us
the problem with making sensible
decisions is that
so is everyone else and you see a guy
sort of standing in these
between all these cages and these cages
are everyone else's decision
in a way this is a compliment to that
previous page
we're imprisoned by other people's
expectations their
opinions their beliefs their decisions
that they make and we feel as though
we need to make the same decisions as
them why did dmx stand out so much
because he wasn't making the same
decisions
as everyone else with his music his
music was utterly different
i mean you could there's probably some
nods to tupac
and some other you know greats but like
it was
it was unique it was its own thing yeah
because he wasn't trying to yeah well
let me map out the someone else's
blueprint and turn that into my music
right well that that fails every time
you become a knockoff version
it's a reason remember when jaw rule
came out after him everyone's like why
do you sound like dmx
it was like well because he was trying
to sound like the mx right
um let me move on here to page we'll do
a couple more of these
this one's really short page 76
is a picture of a bunch of sheep and it
says most people
are other people their thoughts are
someone else's opinions their lives of
mimicry
their passions a quotation
which is ironically a quotation from
oscar wilde
and at the bottom of the page it says
what's your opinion i i appended that i
actually
crossed that opinion and said what's the
truth because
i don't care what your opinion is i
think your opinions your beliefs
it just creates more more of these sheep
here right
if we're following along and creating
all of these beliefs and opinions
in fact that's our beliefs and opinions
that caused us to do all these quote
unquote
bad things bad things let's see what you
did there
[Laughter]
let's move on to page 88 what is a good
idea
there's a picture of well i'm not even
going to tell you what it is but you'll
see it in a moment
one that happens is so one that happens
is a good idea
if it doesn't it isn't when a client
asked how much it would cost to get
permission to photograph the eiffel
tower for use in an advertisement
the bureaucrats representing the city of
paris said
ten thousand pounds the client didn't
think that was such a good idea anymore
so they didn't use it i wanted to use it
for this book
but i don't think 10 000 pounds is such
a good idea either
so i didn't ask boom and here's a
picture of the eiffel tower in this book
and he didn't have to pay anyone for it
it's not to say steal someone else's
work but no one owns the rights to
being able to photograph the eiffel
tower yeah but if you're willing to pay
someone for it they're gonna take your
money
yeah all right let's move on to actually
let's
let's just talk about this um as we're
talking about
the opposite it's a great book man do
you have any examples ryan
of thinking the opposite when you've
benefited from maybe thinking the
opposite
oh i think the first
there's so many examples um i remember
in high school
i used to go out of my way with teachers
to
um be as nice and courteous as possible
and then when i got in trouble
instead of being defensive i was like
you know what i'm gonna like
not be defensive and i'm gonna think the
opposite here and i'm going to
uh act like an adult and more often than
not if i got in trouble for something i
would have
um i don't want to say gotten away with
it but i didn't get
in as much trouble as maybe i should
have gotten in trouble yeah
uh so that i mean that's like probably
the earliest example um but in the
corporate days i remember
um we used to have those uh those chats
with our the ceo of our company yes his
name sort of rhymes with chat
yeah so we were on chat chats with chat
chats with chet and i remember being
uh it was my very first chat with chet
i was a bottom level bottom rung
employee
sales person and i remember this still
yeah and it was so good
he was going on and on and on about how
great these new plans were
and i don't even want to sit here and
describe what the what the cell phone
plan was but he was like this is like
going to change our whole company
but and i just was sitting there in my
head and i was thinking
he couldn't be more wrong like this is a
really this is not a good plan this is
not a good deal
because you dealt with customers and he
didn't right exactly so
a piece of me was like don't say
anything man like just
like people you're not supposed to say
anything right no one was saying
anything
so um i thought the opposite
i uh was like you know what i don't
really have anything to lose right now
yeah uh if i get fired from this job
it's not the end of the world
um so uh i'm gonna go and speak my mind
because that's really what should be
done
even though it's kind of frowned upon
and so i raised my hand i'm like i don't
think
you're correct about these these cell
phone plans he's like what do you mean
you don't think i'm crazy
and i was like well you know you've got
i kind of laid it out for him when it
was and i
i uh was talking about the pricing on
you know per
per minute charge back in the day when
we used to charge per minute for cell
phone plans
and uh i was like you know you know it
costs x you know like
i was like 15 or 20 cents or something
like that a minute and he was like which
is it
15 or 20 cents and i was like i don't
know which is it and he looks over at
the um the uh uh regional director or
whatever
and he's like oh hey uh whatever her
name was hey how how much is it she was
like oh it's 15 cents and he was like
it's 15 cents
why didn't you know that it's your job
to know that i'm like dude you're the
ceo of the company you didn't know that
and uh it did act and it did just that
it got a good laugh from the crowd
but you know long story short what he
did is he
um he owned what i said is
he took that in um he he owned the fact
that maybe it wasn't the best idea
and uh he actually like made this
meeting
he he he uh planned this meeting with me
to meet with marketers
and a couple other people to really
flesh out
what would be appropriate runs below him
on the ladder
yes now the the the crazy thing is is
like that
actually inspired me to speak up more
yes
um and i climbed the corporate ladder
really quickly in that company
because i spoke up yeah so it it you
know in that sense it was the opposite
of what
everyone else was doing um everyone else
was being the sheep falling in line
and uh yeah i spoke up and i
didn't i didn't care to stand out and i
and maybe that's what the whole
i think that's what the one of the
lessons in this book
is you want to stand out for better or
worse i mean i forget
i forget what page number it's on in
here but they talk about how
someone who has a different idea or an
opposite idea
they they so for example for me i had
that opposite
you know reaction i got put you know
into this position
um to kind of affect uh some change with
those plans
but then you know let's say i had 20 bad
ideas after that
i was still remembered for that one idea
and then people
you know after 20 bad ideas they kind of
brush me off
but then that 21st idea that's another
one of those think the opposite
great ideas and they're like oh yeah
that is good right so
you're only you're really only
remembered and the book talks about this
you're remembered only
for the really good ideas that you have
peaks and valleys
yes so you may have 99 bad ideas
but that one good idea is what's going
to stand out and then
then you have two you know then you have
198 bad ideas but then you got two that
stands out and you're building
this reputation you're building this
resume of thinking different
even though you're wrong the majority of
the time when you're right you're really
really right it's why a lot of these
sports announcers that they stay
relevant because
they have all these terrible takes but
then one of them is actually
it comes true yeah and you're like oh
yeah you know
stephen a smith predicted this and
you're like well yeah but look at the
other 20 things no one's saying like but
yeah we predicted these 20 things and
they're all garbage
it's like no they they stand out the the
only
the only sort of thing that opposes that
is if you have something that is
catastrophically a bad idea that causes
harm
then obviously those things stand out as
well yeah and that i mean yeah i would
say
your ideas have to be appropriate for
sure so a couple times
real quick some examples that have
benefited me from thinking
the opposite it's always when it's
something we're supposed to do
you know you're supposed to go to
college you know i don't have a college
degree right
it's not that it's wrong to have one
it's not wrong to not have one either
you're supposed to get married you're
supposed to own a home
you're supposed to be monogamous you
know uh bax and i were just talking
about monogamy and sort of redefining
monogamy on our podcast it's called how
to love by the way
if you want to check it out wherever you
listen to podcasts dude the thing that
stands out most to me about you thinking
the opposite is when you laid yourself
off
oh wow hands down man like that is the
biggest moment that stands out
okay or like maybe the first moment i
really saw because when you're given the
task
hey josh i'm giving you the task of
laying people off in the company that's
a great position to be in because well
guess what
you're not gonna lay yourself off yeah
i'm the most safe person right
exactly yeah and you like thought the
opposite and you're like this is
actually a good opportunity for me to
to seize yeah because i realized how
unsafe it was in staying
and i'm glad i did because eventually
that company was bought and
i'm sure the deck chairs continue to be
a rearrange by the way even if it
wouldn't and i would have stayed
it was unsafe in other ways it was
unsafe for my tranquility for my peace
for my
freedom it lacked all of those things
even though i earned a paycheck to buy a
bunch of things that weren't
bringing me happiness thank goodness for
minimalism which we're going to talk
about now we have a question here
from lee in portland maine i
have been thinking a lot about
retirement
y'all tend to talk about it a lot i
really appreciate
your approach to saving and it
definitely made me think a lot about you
know starting to stay with 20 year old
and
and just getting going on it so that's
great but
something we talked about in my ethics
class uh this past semester
was about how retirement can actually be
detrimental to a person's
not well-being but to a person's
growth and development which are two
things that i think y'all really
appreciate and um you know tend to work
on
and so i i wanted some clarification on
maybe what retirement
you know i know it's really down the
road for you two but
you know what that looks like so talk
about thinking the opposite here ryan
i think the opposite in so many ways
with respect to retirement so i'll give
you a few things one is i retired about
10 years ago
when i laid myself off yeah now it
doesn't mean that i am set for life i
don't have enough money in fact i was
still in a little bit of debt at the
time
and i was living off of 23 000 a year we
had just started this business together
and
we were sort of scraping buys living in
a 500 a month apartment with no other
bills other than the basic utilities
and making it work i didn't even have
internet at home
because i i couldn't afford it and so
i'd go to local coffee shop or library
or your house right where you were still
in the corporate world
and i would and what i realized is like
well it depends what you mean by
retirement here if you talk about
retirement savings yeah i still put
money in at least 20
of my income every month into a sep ira
or a um s p 500 index funds yeah
and and so ryan and i invest money in
the future there's nothing wrong with
money we're not allergic to money
money creates a cert if you're going to
live in society so if you're not going
to do the ted kaczynski thing
uh without the bombing and stuff but
like just living in a cabin in the
middle of nowhere
uh thoreau thing is maybe a better way
to put it even throw is a bad example
because his mom did his laundry
right so uh but if you're not gonna do a
cab in the middle of nowhere
off the grid then you're what you're
doing is you're saying i have agreed to
live in society within civilization
in order to do that you have to have
some sort of currency our currency is
called
money and and that might be replaced in
the future by bitcoin or something else
but right now it's money money allows us
to have a certain amount of freedom
however how we spend our money often
tethers us
and i think that's what we're talking
about with lee here is
how we spend our money actually takes
away our freedom so the money gives you
the freedom and then all of a sudden we
feel the need to spend it on things we
don't need
it's removing our freedom
is that what is that what she's saying
because because i am a little confused
with how
how is retirement detrimental how is
planning for retirement dental mental
it's when
it's once you save the money and then
you go and retire
yeah she's not saying that planning
she's saying you're you're right
once you retire you know if you stop
growing you die is the the phrase i mean
the average
lifespan of a male who retires is what
like three years or so three years after
retirement if you look at amortization
tables of insurance companies right
uh and and so uh that because they lose
a per they lose their purpose
they they lose a sense yeah purpose
meaning in their life so really to
append her
question it's in her philosophy class
they posited that if you retire without
a purpose it's going to be detrimental
to your health right and so what we did
is
we at age 30 retired with a purpose
pretty much
and we still have to earn a living and
money
is still a part of that and we don't
pretend that it isn't right it's no
longer in
the driver's seat it no longer makes the
primary decisions
however by the way there's an essay put
a link to this in the show notes so you
can see exactly how ryan and i plan for
retirement
uh in fact uh ryan has a financial
freedom e-book that we put together
if you go to the minimalists.com budget
it'll show you a lot of the
the sort of the ways that we plan that
way we want to get into the details here
but i do want to talk about this thing
with growth because
i used to believe that growth was
just great all the time no matter how
you're growing it was good growth is
good
right well that's not true and in our
new book which is called love people use
things i'll hold it up here for the
camera it comes out july 13th by the way
we're getting ready to record the
audiobook i love how the word opposite
is in red
for this the opposite never works a lot
of people use things because the
opposite never works
what an astute observation ryan and
speaking of astute observation so in our
first book which is called minimalism
live a meaningful life we talk about the
five foundational values now there's a
values chapter in here
and we highlight those briefly on a page
or so
and then i talk about one of those is
growth growth and contribution of the
last two in minimalism of a meaningful
life
and and in here i append what i
said in that first book about growth
with
comparing responsible growth or i think
in the final version i actually call it
intentional growth
and never-ending growth our society is
predicated on
never-ending growth oh my god think
about it give me some examples here of
never-ending growth
the more the market the stock market yes
it's supposed to just grow and grow and
grow and it does
the gdp grow but it can't last forever
right i mean eventually it's got to like
yeah it's got to have its valley
but when that grows other things grow as
well like cost of living so it's not
actual growth there because
sometimes cost of living outpaces
inflation and all of a sudden it looks
like the growth
but it's actually a decline in a way
what was the stat you told me about
all the money ever printed out of all
the money ever printed 30 percent of it
was printed last year in the united
states 37
of of all 37 yeah my god yeah
was printed in one year what does that
do it causes staggering inflation that's
a type of growth now let's talk about
other kinds of growth so this is an
excerpt from love people use things
please pre-order it now if you can
lovepeopleusethings.net or find it on
amazon barnes and noble your local
bookstore
if you don't you're dead to us yes now
is the time to do it this really helps
us out if you pre-order the book
and you'll get it the day that it comes
out we'll also even read it to you if
you'd like because we're doing the
audiobook next week that's right
anyway this is a excerpt from the fourth
relationship chapter so this book's
about the seven different relationships
in our lives
one is our relationship with our values
and so it goes something like this
of course not all growth is beneficial a
bicep
after a month in the gym is a type of
growth but
so is a tumor and that's where i really
didn't
account for in our first book was like
growth does feel like it's a
quote unquote good thing right yeah i
mean it's kind of implied right when we
say growth and contribution
i mean we are talking about a
responsible growth intentional growth
but
the yeah so the connotations there but
yeah the yeah we need to be careful
though because yes there are
two types of growth but so is a tumor so
we better choose deliberately how we
want to grow
or will grow according to the dictates
of everyone else
our society has developed a particular
narrative since the industrial
revolution
one that says we must explore
never-ending growth
which might sound appealing at first but
it's not the type of growth
i'm interested in what i'm focused on
is intentional growth never-ending
growth says we must grow at any cost
intentional growth happens when we grow
in accordance with our values have you
ever
made a quote one time compromise that
led to a series of
greater compromises i have i've
literally lied and stolen to get what i
wanted
there's a story earlier in this book
where actually in this chapter where i
talk about shoplifting oh my gosh uh and
being arrested and
and uh fingerprinted and all that fun
stuff i just have like this wave of
emotion thinking about
those little decisions that just lead to
other little decisions that lead to
other little decisions and then
yeah you look in the rear view and
you're like oh my god what have i done
right yeah yeah exactly and in the
moment it doesn't feel like much
right but then it adds up really quickly
so so
but then i didn't stop with the first
indiscretion
i'd lie to cover up the previous lie and
then i'd need to tell an even bigger lie
to cover up the cover-up
what a tangled web this often happens
when we compromise even though there's
nothing
intrinsic intrinsically wrong with
compromise itself in fact most
relationships require
continually meeting in the middle the
problem occurs when we compromise
what we want to get what we want
today tweet that podcast sean so
think about that we compromise what we
want what we truly desire
to get what we want today right now
instant gratification right
it's harder to stick to our principles
to avoid the allure of the shortcut
but it's important if we want to grow
the right way never ending growth
forsakes people
for profitability that's another problem
with never ending growth
it's not about people lover it's about
the almighty dollar
intentional growth doesn't pretend money
is irrelevant but it doesn't allow the
profit motive to run the show
either ryan and i run two profitable
businesses the minimalist in los angeles
california and bandit coffee co in st
petersburg florida but money is not the
primary driver for either
we focus on adding value to our readers
listeners viewers followers clients and
customers
without undermining our values we treat
our employees fairly and pay them good
wages
fair wages we focus on
quality not quantity we don't run
advertisements on any of our platforms
we don't sell our audience's data to
third parties
and we don't send spam or junk to anyone
ever as a result people trust us and
they're willing
to support our work be it the books we
write or the coffee we
roast the minimalist coffee by the way
if you want some coffee
and coffee rose sure we may not squeeze
every nickel out of either business this
quarter
but it's easier to sleep at night
knowing we're doing the right thing
and we feel better about the long-term
prospects of both enterprises
when their growth isn't predicated
solely on padding our
wallets one more thing here one
never-ending growth
worries about competition and increased
expectations
intentional growth contemplates
cooperation
and higher standards think about that
you could tweet any of these podcasts
sean these all sort of stand out here
because
yeah well i'll just go on to say this
during my corporate days we fixated so
heavily on imaginary targets
my retail stores are responsible for
tracking 29 different performance
metrics on a daily basis you remember
that well ryan
which meant that even on a quote great
sales day
we could always find something to make
us discontented um
always yeah i remember that was like
when my
boss came at me for not getting more
than 120
or 130 percent of my goal yeah it was
just like
oh like you're you're never going to be
satisfied yes yeah
and that's never-ending growth is
never-ending
dissatisfaction never-ending growth is
never-ending dissatisfaction yeah that's
good
we do this in our personal lives too
don't we we look at the scale in our
bathroom and pretend it's readout is a
proxy for well-being
we look at the numbers on our bank
statement and pretend they're a proxy
for happiness
we look at the material possessions in
our home and pretend they are a proxy
for completeness
these expectations only grow in time
what was once
a grand hope becomes commonplace is our
expectations expand
creating chaos along the way the
antidote to this chaos
is a bit of a paradox to restore order
in our lives
we must lower our expectations but raise
our standards and i go on to give an
example of how we can do that i'm not
going to read all of that here but
what i will say is lee let me send you a
copy of
love people use things you're going to
get an advanced copy for your question
because yes retirement
can mean one thing and it can mean
the loss the death of purpose the death
of meaning in your life or
it could mean that oh i didn't really
find meaning in what i was doing
i can move on to something meaningful i
work a lot
now but it almost feels like a
compulsion i don't feel as though
i i have to do it but
i have to do it yeah does that make
sense it does
lee enjoy that book if you like the uh
uh the podcast i think you'll enjoy
this or if you want the audiobook
version even we can send that to you
once it
is finished up to you morgan has a
little comment here ryan i want to read
this real quick this is from our
online city minimalist.org meetup group
so we have a
hundred free local meetup groups over at
minimalist.org if one of those
isn't in a city near you it's eight
different countries we also have this
online city which is thriving i think
there's
14 or 15 000 people in this group and
occasionally i'll just hop in there and
i'll interact with some folks it's
actually probably the place
besides patreon that i interact with
people the most
is here at minimalist.org in the online
city
so morgan said i had five pillows in my
garage waiting to be
washed for the last three months today i
put them
in the dumpster i was listening to the
minimalist hoarders podcast on youtube
and they described what hoarding is
the different levels yes she said i am a
level two and so you and i we talk so
go back and listen to that podcast if
you'd like we did a whole podcast on
hoarders very recently sean will put a
link to that in the show notes
and i really enjoyed the maximal episode
we did for that as well you can find
that on
the minimalist private podcast but i
responded to her
and i just said congratulations for
letting go and she said that's it
just letting go is so hard i literally
got rid of
one half of our stuff after watching
minimalism but now i'm stuck with legos
and stuff from my kids who are now 19
and 14
but i'm having a hard time and i just
responded with remember letting go
isn't something you do it's something
you stop
doing you stop clinging you stop
worrying about what other people are
thinking
about other people's expectations you
drop it
not prescriptively but you simply let it
go
because you're not holding on to it
anymore
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it is time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed during the
lightning round so ryan and i do our
best
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place as well minimal
maxims.com all right we got a question
from annie
some of the worst advice i've received
is
fake it until you make it what is wrong
with being a work in
progress it's funny because i actually
think that's not good or bad advice it's
just it can be either really that's
that's a really great point so it's
contextual right
yeah in fact it's only bad advice if
we're searching for good advice
in a way yeah why don't you start with
your pithy answer i know you've got some
stuff for us so my pithy answer is all
advice
is bad advice and let's talk about why
that is because i obviously agree with
that yeah we have to unpack it
because if you just tweet that it's
going to be incendiary
and and what you and i have talked about
is like we're trying to get out of the
advice business not because we don't
want to help people
but because what we're trying to do is
observe
in a way that doesn't put us on a
pedestal yeah i'm not better
than you the the dmx thing it's not that
he was better than i mean he was better
looking than us
but that's not within our control anyway
right right but
the the thing was i wasn't it's not
about
doling out advice because that puts me
on a pedestal but i can make some
observations while i'm standing right
next to you
yeah and the truth is you can make those
same observations and have that same
understanding
if you also choose to wake up so when
you say
all advice is bad advice what you're
saying is
as we're constantly looking for someone
else's advice
that is going to be detrimental to our
own
sort of intentional growth yeah i mean
sometimes people get caught up in
looking for advice or looking for the
solution
rather than just taking some actions
so the fake until you make it advice for
me i look at that
as you know it could be good if let's
say i wanted to um
be really healthy and be like in the
best shape of my life
like i would wake up in the morning and
i would ask myself what would the
healthiest person in the world do right
now
like are they going to eat a blueberry
muffin
or are they going to drink a big glass
of water and then maybe go for a walk
so fake it till you make it isn't
terrible advice
uh unless you think that that is the
answer
now if you think fake it till you make
it is the answer then it is going to be
the wrong advice i could have said all
the devices good advice
also okay and it would have applied well
so so i don't know that i agree with
that and let me let me say
why because when i talk about advice
maybe all
observations are good observations
something like that but
but there is something with because
advice comes from a place of
here's what i think is right and and
therefore
it moralizes something in a way
and so the the fake it till you make it
thing the the problem i have with that
is i don't want
to fake it right i want to be authentic
until i make it and by the way we've
already made it and so
thinking we have to make it is also bad
advice because you've already made it
you're already there
wherever you are you are there but
what i really want to talk about is the
second part of this question what is
wrong with
being a work in progress here's my pithy
answer we can unpack it
progress is achieved not through
addition
but through subtraction so
think about that for a moment if we want
to make progress we're
all often trying to do something in fact
on the private podcast this week i'm
going to talk about the problem
with doing i have an essay called
changing your life won't change your
life
and and what i really mean by that is
quite often we try to do a bunch of
things because we see other people
they dole out the advice is what you
should do what you're supposed to do
i want to think the opposite the only
thing that i
want to progress at is figuring out what
is essential
and to get what is essential in our
society
unless you're living in extreme
deprivation we already have
enough and identifying a couple weeks
we're going to do a podcast episode
about enough
ism and and identifying what is enough
is so critical because
if you do that it's almost never the
adding that gets you to enough
yeah it's always the subtracting it's
the laying yourself off
it's the getting rid of home internet
because i couldn't afford it and i
didn't want to be tethered to that
lifestyle
it's always through subtraction and the
things we add after that are almost
always incidental in a way
they're cosmetic or mechanical but the
profound
progress becomes from from
subtracting our friend chris ryan wrote
a book called civilized to death the
subtitle of which is
the price what is the price of progress
well think about that
progress we often think about is getting
more having
more needing more growing responsible
growth or even just
never-ending growth well okay
but what is the price of that growth
if you give up your equanimity and
tranquility
to get everything you've actually lost
everything
it goes back to that that's the metaphor
in dmx's butterfly story
is he ruined all the beautiful things
at the cost of getting what he wanted
yes the butterfly oh that's beautiful
um yeah you know it's it's so hard
because of the way we've been
kind of thinking lately and trying to
get out of the advice business
it really has me looking at everything
as a two-sided coin
seeing and i'll tell you like i mean
just a little here's a little taste of
the maximal segment we're gonna talk
about bad advice let me read two of
these bad advices
do it joyce says it's a good thing
this is this is bad advice that she
received it's a good thing to always
have some debt and payments that's the
bad advice she received
maggie or the bad advice she received
was never have debt or use it to build
credit uh-huh
it's complete opposite of each other yes
one one is uh saying the exact opposite
of the other and that's
that's what has me looking at everything
as a two-sided coin and why i'm saying
all advice is
bad advice or hey you know what all
advice is good advice
depends on what you do with it maybe you
give me a piece of crappy advice and i'm
like
oh i know i shouldn't act on that
in a way that was good advice right in a
way what not to do
a roundabout way yeah i think quite
often in fact
any of that advice if it helps you
identify what not to do
that's when it does become the good
advice that's where we right
where we converge here so so the the
problem though
lies and you've been saying this a lot
the problem is the solution
so i would append that and i would say i
say it the other way around but that
that's good too yeah
oh the solution is a problem yeah but so
i would append that and i would say the
advice is the problem
and uh it's if we're if we're seeking
only advice
it's not gonna get us anywhere it's
going to uh do what everyone else has
done it's gonna that's where it's gonna
lead us it's gonna lead us to
working out yeah it's gonna lead us to
mediocrity which is okay there's nothing
wrong with being
i'm mediocre in a lot of things me too
um
but but if you're seeking advice and
you're only acting on the
quote good advice then you're gonna be
media you're gonna be uh yeah
mediocre well think about mediocre
mediocre
think about how potato tomato
think of how how uh you've tried to
improve your life
how is that working out by adding
is buying the new thing improving your
life
no it's not you're already complete it's
not making your life more complete
how is betterment helping you out it's
not really
it might for a moment but when we're
talking about lasting
change it's always internal it has to do
with
an understanding an awareness a seeing
reality for what it is and we have to
uncover that
through subtraction yeah we're gonna
talk so much more about that but ryan
what do you have for us first here are
some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners
hi my name's emma um i'm from fresno
california
i just wanted to leave a comment for
listeners um
when i tried to do minimalism i noticed
that as a woman i had so many products
as far as makeup lotions perfumes
makeup remover and just a lot of
bathroom products
so i looked into more natural ways to
get more function out of products and i
went ahead and switched over to using
coconut oil
which can be used to
for basically any products that i had i
was able to replace it with coconut oil
and i went ahead and just threw away a
bunch
of the products i had and it really
minimized
the amount of clutter i had under my
sink in my bathroom which
was really freeing so just wanted to
share that tip thanks
hi my name is nikia and i am from
nebraska
and listening to the spouse's episode it
really got my mind
wandering of some guilt that i had been
holding on to
my husband um when we were dating i
got rid of some of his things such as a
packers
poster and i got rid of some golfing
things and some
bowling things and we don't live in a
house where
there's room for a man cave or a she
shed
but i really just
decided that and with the help of my
spouse we talked about it and we decided
that we don't need a space in our home
that is dedicated to things that we wish
we would be doing
so we have pledged to each other that
instead of deciding that we want to hang
brett favre
on our wall my husband is more than
welcome to go watch a packers game or
maybe someday we'll get to go
um instead of having phil mickelson
up on our wall or having a glove with
his name on it
we can just go ahead and he can go
golfing or perhaps get to go to
one of our one of his
things that he does in golf so
um that's just my suggestion just to
just to go and do the things versus
surrounding yourself
with the things that you wish you would
be doing all right y'all we got a bunch
more questions this thursday on patreon
that's the maximum episode on the
minimalist private podcast
the minimalists.com support if you want
to be a subscriber over there
but first real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life
of the minimalists you've heard me talk
about this well it's finally opening
back up ryan
it's been seven years in the making but
finally the new
version the brand new version of how to
write better my writing class
launches on friday may 7. nice
it's open for 48 hours only you can
get details over how to
howtowritebetter.org but josh what if i
already paid for the old version oh what
a great question ryan
then pay for this one too no just
kidding if you paid for the old version
you took the class
if you took the class you get this new
version
at no additional charge and so we're
going to reach out to you if you
did take the class previously you will
get this one you don't have to pay a
dime
if you're interested in taking the class
it's only 100 students the enroll or
48 hours whichever comes first so
sometimes the class sells out in 24
hours i suspect this one
might as well because it's the brand new
version jordan did an amazing job on all
these videos
we're still doing the final edits as we
record this but
we we came in and we redid the entire
class
all of the the course materials it's
like 60 pages of course materials
how many videos we do like 20 30 40 i
don't know how many it's a ton of videos
and the class goes through your email
it's four weeks long you can take it
whatever time frame you want ryan you've
taken the class in the past
yeah it's great it's uh it's a habits
course really is what it is
yeah but it really gets granular with
your habits and yeah why they're
important and it's about yeah
understanding the habits instead of just
saying
let's do this thing and then we talk
about composition we talk about editing
the second week's all about composition
the third week's all about editing the
fourth week is about getting your work
out in front of people so
writing so that you can be read by an
audience and so i talk about how you and
i developed an audience over the last
decade or so and so you can check that
out howtowrightbetter.org
you can sign up for the email list over
there you'll also get the free ebook
it's called 11 ways to write better and
we'll notify you as soon as the class
opens of course i'll never send you spam
or junk or
anything like that how to write
better.org i feel like
we really should have talked about how
when we decided to simplify our lives
that's
another example of thinking the opposite
because everyone's looking for more
more and more and more and then we get
introduced to minimalism and we were
like oh
yes what if we did less what if we
focused on getting less
yes um but if it wasn't for thinking the
opposite that way
we wouldn't be here right now totally i
mean that's that's uh
the whole reason why we're here right
now is we started thinking the opposite
we we were going after less instead of
more
yeah and what got us into trouble was
the growth
was the more was the the debt
yeah yeah yeah the the striving the
chasing the pursuit
the pleasure all of those things the
same things that got dmx
in trouble the the pursuit of pleasure
and
and the escapism yeah
the reason he had i identify with his
story if not his music
so much was that i
see humanity in him obviously i see
myself in him but no i see
all of humanity and our struggles
and our struggles aren't fixed by
amassing more
and when you and i began to think the
opposite what do we remove
what do we subtract what is enough
by the way just asking that question
what is enough is thinking the opposite
yeah no one asked that question the
question earlier with lee
when you talk about retirement okay what
does retirement mean for you what is
enough
because if you identify what enough is
then you can back into that number right
and once you've identified enough
then you almost always subtract occasion
you might have to add
but when you've identified enough then
you know where you go from here and what
by the way the actions then just happen
on their own you don't have to do
some actions that someone advised you to
do
you know what to do when you know what
enough is you can tweet that podcast
sean
ryan for added value this week my
favorite dmx song is called slipping
it's off his second album
flesh of my flesh blood of my blood and
by the way listen for a little beautiful
surprise
at the end of the song a little
something special
that i found from 2016 from dmx
enjoy the song it's called slipping we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like
what are 10 things people are going to
leave behind after the pandemic
why doesn't decluttering or habit change
work
and we're going to examine some of the
worst advice ever given
plus a million more questions for the
minimalist and if you want to hear all
that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week visit theminimists.com
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app join 6 000
or so
other listeners over there we have a
whole community it's thriving
and by the way you get all of our
archives talk about
more much more of less
some amazing conversations over there
they're longer form conversations than
the shorter podcasts that we do
for the public it's a place that we can
let our hair down we can talk about some
things
that we don't always talk about in
public some things we may even be afraid
to talk about
in public that's the minimalist private
podcast the minimalists.com
support to subscribe you can follow the
minimalist on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalist
come to one of our live podcast shows
which are starting again real soon visit
the minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com comment
on this episode
at youtube.com the minimalist if you
want our show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com
what won't we send you spam junk
junkie spam no advertisements but we
will send you any of our minimalist
writings for free whenever those are
published as well and if you leave here
today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it